Hassan, don't you know that we built this whole snarking thing
to protect you as you're going to turn the very thing we built
to protect you on yourself? Don't do it. Don't do it. Hassan
>> Kuan JSTLK and a bunch of XX Pesty fans supporting Casey
Tron and the girls. No, I know. At least an hour of uninterrupted
footage of Asmin Gold first demanding that I get deplatformed,
then demanding that I get sued, then demanding that the federal
government prosecute me, and then celebrating the federal government
implying that they might. So, [laughter]
well, to the Singaporean authorities, I would like to [music]
report I am very scared. I feel very threatened that this person
has made 358
videos on me. This is alarming.
363.
Sorry. It's alarming. It's very scary.
I
was intending to visit Singapore soon and now I don't even know
if if I could do that. It's truly a terrifying prospect for me.
It seems kind of obsessive. It seems kind of like cyberstalking.
Not entirely certain if that's a there's a statute for cyber
stalking in general. Public threats, long-term harassment, daily
videos that he's monetizing. I hope someone in in uh the Singaporean
authorities could could potentially look into this. Um if you
if you know like a good Singaporean lawyer, something like that,
it'd be nice to to try and figure out if I could pursue litigation
of sorts. Lau, why are you fantasizing about this? I mean, it'd
be pretty funny if he actually got in >> What do we do
next? So, we've got some Hutch stuff. We've got some Hassan stuff.
Maybe we go through some of this denim stuff. Okay. I've heard
that
in response to the denim stuff, Hassan did a little bit of a
string today. We could check out some highlights from that. I'll
I'll look around in it. Okay. Oh, this the >> By the way,
it worked. >> Wait, what? >> The update. So, the
situation did get me thinking that I should probably make more
variety videos. Not because I'm going to get sued. He's not.
[laughter]
>> It wasn't about dude. I don't think he wanted you sued.
I never got the impression Hassan wanted Pegasus sued. I got
the impression Hassan wanted the cops to go visit Pegasus.
That's that's the impression I got. I never got the impression
he was looking to sue this guy at all.
I didn't get the impression he was threatening litigation. I
got the impression he was threatening the cops. And I didn't
like that. That he was saying like he was obviously joking. No,
he wasn't. No, he wasn't. No, he wasn't. No, he wasn't. He was
not joking. It's too far. >> Not winning that. But just
for my own enjoyment, I used to make a lot of variety. I also
recently wanted to talk about KSI leaving the sidemen the bricks
and minifigs that iffy >> it worked. I got to do this more.
What
Don't don't don't. You're falling down the Ethan Klein path.
Don't do it. Don't do it. Don't do it. Hassan,
don't do it. This Hassan, don't you know that we built this whole
snarking thing to protect you and you're going to turn the very
thing we built to protect you on yourself? Don't do it. Don't
do it. Hassan, you can't do it. Stop. Nah, he's probably still
going to keep making
>> He remembered he's not in America. He remembered he
lives in Singapore. Let me make some calls real quick, dude.
Let me make some goddamn calls.
By the way, I never got the impression Hassan was going to call
the cops. I do get the impression when Hassan pulls this guy
up and looks over the law and goes, "Oh, this guy's like clearly
breaking the law. Someone in Singapore should do something about
this." I do get the impression he's basically calling on his
audience to call the cops on this guy. Sorry, that seems pretty
obvious to me. Even if even if later he says it's just a joke,
I do think he's
I do think Okay, you could he could say he needs to be wedging
in a lot of those. Don't do anything. I'm just around with this
guy.
I'm just around with this guy. I'm just around with this guy.
He just needs to keep doing it.
Oh, we need to move all your haters to Singapore. Yeah, this
is like Techone. He won't be able to stop himself. He's too addicted
to you. Yeah. You mean who's techone? I only know.
Okay. Just like that, I'm back on the team. [laughter]
Remember how he was going to win that court case, too, and everyone
was dumb enough to believe him? >> And we're back.
>> Yeah, dude. It's always funny. I mean, there have been
numerous examples of like the real world meeting the internet
world. Like Chud the Builder is another great example of this
is a great example of this where like created this like environment
around himself where he was like I'm defeating this court case.
It's
isn't joking. He threatened and it worked. Simple as h I think
he was like talking about in a way that he was basically going
to go well how how could I know someone called would call the
cops on this guy
if if more Pegasus had some pull in that country. It'd be awesome
if he like faked his arrest and and then everybody blamed his
son [laughter] for Could you imagine if this guy got arrested?
Like somebody did call and then he does get arrested and then
he actually does geted for it. No, not even the faking part,
but like could you imagine if that actually happened to him?
That'd be crazy, right?
>> Don't you I think Hassan would feel bad. I would hope
Hassan would feel bad if they if they did call the cops on him
and suddenly you just see this guy get >> wait to destroy
all my enemies blah blah blah all this and then what happened?
What happened? It turns out straight up we were right. We were
right. He was a right similar thing took place with Chud the
Builder. That is the one area where the internet world and memes
don't matter in the real world when you're forced to actually
exist in the real world and there's like actual adults with power
over you that oversee your court case. You can't just like [__]
meme your way out of it. Chud the Builder is going through that
right now. He had a great time harassing black people over and
over again, doing hate crimes over and over again until he shot
himself in the process of trying to shoot a black person outside
of another uh court case that he was dealing with. And now he's
in prison. Like your clapbacks don't matter. You know, your clapbacks
don't actually matter in a court of law. >> It's just an
ongoing sequence of harassments and and justifications for harassments.
even if like the person doing the harassment
is is engaging in an act that you would otherwise find unconscionable
if it was done to you, right? Even if there is validity
to uh taking legal action in a certain situation. We saw this
with Alyssa,
the former Kotaku writer who is now successfully suing
what is his name? Smash JT or whatever. >> Smash JT. and
has has >> dude I don't cover that at all. I I've heard
that's been really good. I just never have had the chance to
ever go catch up on it. >> Basically destroyed him
and it's perfectly valid for the record uh to do so. This guy,
what was his name? Smash JT. Alysa Mercante is the is the Kotaku
reported that Asmin Gold and all these other monsters have been
uh bullying and belittling nonstop, right?
And uh a big vector of that hatred came from this guy
smash JT
>> reactionary content creator
um total idiot right
>> and Alyssa after years and years of withstanding harassment
from this guy turned around and took him to court >> and
for the longest time before the court proceeding >> what
was the the core defamation is that he called Alyssa he said
Alyssa was like a prostitute that she was like an escort Right.
And she basically said, "Well, that's you just accused me of
a crime. That's slander. Take it down." And then that's the genesis
of the court case, >> Started. Smash GT was saying, "Oh,
yeah. Sue me. Who gives a?" And now that he is being sued for
online harassment, the the most the consistent online harassment
that that you know I've experienced, that Morgan has experienced,
that Casey Tron has experienced, that Denims has experienced.
Right now that she's actually successfully suing him, all of
a sudden all of a sudden the guy's crying. He's like, "I have
a family. You're ruining my life."
>> Here's the thing. If you're gonna sue somebody for like
totally lying, like making up a totally degenerate lie that they
will not take back about you, like if if Tee really had no allegations,
if Teeone was like pretty much fine, and he wanted to sue people
for calling him a like if he didn't lose that case, if he hadn't
had those allegations and people were just calling him that,
to call him that, I would be okay with suing overt lies. I believe
like overt it would have to be like bright line like as in this
is essentially provable that's that it is a lie and you've been
given that information and you persist in that lie. I think I'm
okay with people being sued for that. You know what I mean?
Stuff that's like more subjective obviously not but man there
are some cases like the Alysa Mante thing could be one of them.
There are some cases where like yeah, I do think if you could
be sued effectively for defamation in the US, like beyond it
getting slapped down,
I you're probably up a little bit. Like I I think the Noah Samson
uh beyond the fact that obviously someone can file it and just
basically cost you lawyers fees and cost you a lot of money.
But I'm saying if you actually get sued successfully for defamation,
you're you're really around as an online commentator. Okay, hold
on. I want to skip forward to the denim thing. And this guy says,
"If you speak to Hassan fans, you will be speaking to absolute
lunatics who will threaten to and you over a minor difference
of opinion." That's that's the difference between the two audiences.
Nobody has threatened me with any of those yet.
I'm telling you, I've I've been like hated by multiple different
groups of people, and nothing is quite like being hated by,
you know, the crazy ones. The not the Hassan fans, the Hassan
fans. I never had any problems, man.
I never had any problems at all. It was like it wasn't that bad.
They just don't like you. They're like, you're you're an incel
chud.
>> Okay. And
>> you know, some diddy jers will try to get in and act
like they're Hassan fans. I think Steven is a is a good enough
journalist and also um smart enough to to probably smell that
out.
Like I I I thought about that as well. I thought about that as
well for sure. But I mean, I I trust Stephen uh to to not fall
for like that. Ethan's going to come out tomorrow and be like,
"It was A BIDEN APPOINTED JUDGE. [laughter] THIS WAS AN OBAMA
JUDGE. This was an Obama judge. Clearly,
I demand a
Yeah, his lawyer is a Westbank settler. Apparently, this is the
legal equivalent of your own pants. Yeah. I mean,
some Twitter users did that. Oh, wow. You mean to tell me that
Ethan Klein's newfound audience that is diminishing in size every
single day is increasingly more right-wing and will make unbelievably
stupid statements like that that is very different than what
his original audience used to look like at his peak. Yeah. The
courts have treated me unfairly more unfairly than I've ever
been treated than anyone else has ever been treated. Yeah. The
judge in this case the judge in charge of this case in general
is a Biden autopenire. The only ones coping are you rwords l.
Yeah. Hey, A 2000, maybe cover this, but let's see if you have
enough self-respect. L
This was very funny to me, dude. All I could think is, yeah,
Pisco is going to be unbearable. The next live and learn is going
to be so unbearable from Pisco after this clip right here. Oh
my god.
>> Oh my god.
>> Pisco Lararsps is an attorney, but he's about as qualified
as Mike from PA.
someone like XQC
or or um Asminold could end up with a with a with an opinion
that's like way more broad.
>> Wait, and this couldn't
>> um I suppose, but I think there's less risk in this
situation though, right? Wouldn't you wouldn't you say? >> Why?
Why? >> Because of because of the particular egregious
nature of their malice.
No, but but but that's not an element
in the fair use analysis or in the the test for infringement.
You know, intentional siphoning is not an element, right? I could
I could intend to siphon money from you, but give a fair use
work, right? I could say, I really want to steal from Hutch.
I'm going to do this, but it turns out that my work is fair
>> Good one, Ethan. Good one. Good one,
>> Turns out we were right. Denims want another Hutch el.
Did you address Ethan Klein calling for a vote for Susan Collins
over Platner? No, I didn't because I don't care because he has
nothing.
>> He is literally is is unbelievably irrelevant. Especi
>> It was crazy that he basically said you should vote
for Susan Collins. That was >> when it comes to this issue,
right? Oh man, he's a real mover and shaker in the main Senate
race.
It's called the light most favorable. In evaluating a motion
for judgment on the pleadings, a court must accept all factual
allegations of the complaint as true and conrue them in the light
most favorable to the non-moving party.
What the judge is saying here is I MADE MYSELF BIASED TOWARD
ETHAN.
I said everything Ethan says is true, but with the full context,
you lose
You lose anyway, Ethan. You lose.
>> you guys think Mike's excited? You guys think Mike's
a little excited? Eyes >> toward you. I can't I can't fairly
say that you have a chance of winning. DO YOU UNDERSTAND HOW
MUCH OF an L this is? THIS IS AN EXT LIKE THERE'S NO WAY TO LOSE
HARDER than this legally. Like
>> So what what Mike is saying here, the reason it's biased
is when you move to dismiss essentially they're going to give
the non-moving party as in the plaintiff in this case, not the
defendant because the defendant is moving to dismiss. They're
going to give the nonmoving party the benefit of the doubt on
every ambiguous point. Right? Unfortunately for the non-moving
party, Ethan Klein, the response to this motion, I believe their
first response, they basically give up full
as a fact. It's just a given.
Okay. So this this case is basically just a great example in
like don't let some avoc don't let some some activist lawyer
write your because they'll do something like try to paint the
other person as anti-semitic because they think that's the worst
thing they could possibly say about someone. And what ends up
happening is because you say they're anti-semitic, you end up
proving the fact that it's transformative, that that's the message
they're trying to give out, and you end up making them win the
case. Embarrassing stuff. Okay, this is as bad as it gets. For
reference, winning a motion for judgment on the pleadings as
a defendant is very hard to do. Um, at what point do the courts
determine him a malicious litigant and bar him from future lawsuits?
I don't think it works that way in the United States of America.
I mean, I don't know. What is it called? The vacious litigant,
right? Um, but I don't think that I I think I will say if Ethan
Klein had just ponyied up the money and paid for our boy Andrew
Breler, Andrew Breler would never have made this mistake. Okay,
I can say that categorically. Andrew Breler, he knows his he
would never have made this mistake in a million years. But Ethan
Klein, he was he got a little cheap for some reason. He didn't
he didn't spring for like a big expensive attorney.
I don't know. I don't know what happened, man. >> After
seven. I mean, how does patent trolls work? >> It does
work that way. He'd have to lose five cases in LA. Oh my god.
They're doing a hearing on this motion at 2:15. So, we should
see this ruling finalized then. If that occurs, Ethan loses.
O blocked me so I couldn't retweet it shaking my head. I mean,
for the record, if you guys think that this will be a [__]
turning point for some people, I need you to understand it will
not be. And one of the greatest examples I can
>> dude, the activist judge point from the people in the
Dioro Discord is so funny that that's the that's where they're
going now. They're all running to the activist judge. The the
tone point. It's just an activist judge. No, you fight against
any of the points made in here.
Oh my god. This means I could steal Lord of the Rings and stream
it. No, it
Not even a little bit. Snarker, the snarker influence is spreading
though. Okay, we got we got multiple judges now. Not just one
judge. We got multiple judges. Do you think he could have actually
won the case without all the unforced errors in the suit? Cuz
I don't think I think there's a chance that he could have won
the the trans. Yeah, I think Denims if she had to go through
and prove transformativity.
If she had to go through and prove that, I think that would have
been hard. That would have actually been difficult, right?
But
cuz it's just to me there is something there. Some part of it
has to be the amount of work put into the original work versus
the amount of work put into your work, right? >> But they
didn't do anything. They didn't do anything with it. >> It
was sad.
>> I mean, for the record, if you guys think that this
will be a turning point for some people, I need you to understand
it will not be. And one of the greatest examples I can use is
the issue of Israel, right? Many of these guys, Ethan Klein himself
and all of his little orbiters that that suckled on his teeth
for a year plus or two years plus
literally spent every waking moment attacking people for the
crime of criticizing Israel. They did. They called us terrorists
over and over again. They played games that they designed on
their websites, Asmin Gold and many others, right? And they never
actually turned around and were like, "Yeah, we were wrong about
this Israel shit." They just moved on. Right? So if they're shameless
on this issue where the collective consciousness totally shifted
to our side,
I
that's like one of the things I was saying a while back, right?
That these people never ever basically came out and were like,
you know what, we actually took the wrong side on this. We actually
were kind of wrong in our advocacy and we should know or sorry,
we should acknowledge that. Not know, but they should know, but
also they should acknowledge it. And they never did.
The closest to acknowledgement you got was Destiny going actually
I was always the Palestinian's best advocate [laughter] >> and
they still end up >> actually nobody's more against genocide
than me when you think about it >> calling people like
myself a terrorist people like Morgan a terrorist. I don't think
they're going to do that for this either. I may be I may have
yelled a bit during the coverage of this lau because it was so
cathartic. I actually have seen some people turning on Ethan
good. I hope so.
I hope so. But like
the problem is some of these guys are just simply shameless where
they just they can pull in and out of this issue at a moment's
notice because there's not a lot of buy in, right? The entire
reason as to why they're joining this battle is because you know
how like some people are are misogyny tourists and they weren't
like Tory Lane's fans at all but they just joined in on the fun
to on Megan the Stallion. This is the same principle, right?
These guys are just simply reactionary,
>> right? The the quote was, "I was actually one of Israel's
biggest critics." Yes, >> they have no investment in the
truth whatsoever.
Uh and and for from their perspective, it was a fun opportunity.
It was a a fun opportunity to just like join in on the fun. Uh
belittle and humiliate another female content creator on the
internet.
This is transparently what it was. I don't know if it was misogyny
even. It a lot of it was like Hassan bad, but there were so many
people where I'm like, dude, this Caseyron thing is like disgusting.
Like I if you watch this and you're psyched about it, you should
get your head checked. You should like get off the internet.
you're like an actually disgusting person for liking this that
there's like somebody compelling this speech from her is it's
just gross. It's gross in like every possible way. And there
are so many people like, "Yeah, but she sucks, so it's funny."
It's like, okay, like you you are a loser. You're still a total
loser, man. >> Uh and and get their licks in, right?
>> like I think cruel things can be funny, by the way.
I do think cruel things can be funny, but I just don't think
in this case it's like, dude, I don't I don't around, well, I'm
going to let you out of this lawsuit, but you got to do this
other thing for me. That's it's just crazy. It's crazy that you
can file a lawsuit that you're not even really concerned about
copyright. You just want somebody to apologize to Asmin Gold's
mom or apologize to Asminold about his
It's just bizarre stuff. >> And they move on. When they're
wrong, they just move on. Obviously, there are people who can't
move on from this. Ethan Klein is one of those people. and some
of his closest associates are the people that shouldn't be able
to move on from this. I mean, he literally cannot, right? Here's
the original video I was quote retweeting. >> XQC or or
um Asmin Gold could end up with a with a with an opinion that's
like way more broad. >> Wait, and this couldn't >> um
I suppose, but I think there's less risk in this situation though,
right? Wouldn't you wouldn't you say? >> Why? Why? >> Because
because of the particular egregious nature of their malice. No,
but but that's not an element in the fair use analysis or in
the Pisco LARs as an attorney when he's about as qualified as
Mike from PA. Well, it turns out Pisco and Mike from PA were
actually correct. And the fake legal scholars that you constantly
promoted who are literally MAGA supporting weirdo sex pests,
by the way, like sex tourism lawyers, right? Fake lawyers that
are I don't even know where the these guys live. Half of these
guys are just not in >> Oh, I feel like the whole time,
the whole time with legal mindset, it was like, dude, I with
the techone stuff, I just slowly came to the realization that
tech legal mindset wasn't even looking at the law. He basically
was like, how could I possibly take the more popular side, popular
person side here? How could I do that? Right? It was like totally
It was just obviously like
slanted. It was obviously
Oh, what is it? It was like motivated reasoning the whole time.
And it was just it's funny to see it now like the chickens are
coming home to roost. Okay, it it's obvious you were just you
were just making it up as you went along. >> Real lawyers
at all simply claim to be on YouTube. They were wrong. It turns
out that the guys that you're calling fake lawyers like Pisco
Laring as an attorney were right. Their analysis was right. So
what do you do? The test for infringement. You know, intentional
siphoning is not an element, right? I could I could intend to
siphon money from you but give a fair use work, right? I could
say I really want to steal from Hutch. I'm going to do this.
But it turns out that my work is fair use, right? >> Someone
like XQC or or um Asminold could end up with a with a with an
opinion that's like way more broad. >> Wait, and this couldn't
>> um I suppose.
>> Yeah. Didn't they pass the bar? Didn't they go to law
school? I don't know if Michael passed the bar. I know Mike went
to law school, but I mean Pisco is an actual attorney.
Yeah. He says Denims gets a win in the Ethan Klein copyright
case for new claim the court has held. Tentatively, her reaction
was fair. I'm just I'm just watching this because I know I want
other people to see it and get very angry that Hassan's sitting
here like referencing Pisco being correct. If only other communities
hadn't decided because they liked Ethan Klein more than the truth
that they were going to like totally denigrate Pisco and act
like he was losing his mind and try to gaslight him into, hey
Pisco, you're like just you're just like under the spell of snarkers
actually, right?
Turns out no. Turns out Pisco was just committed to reading the
law faithfully to actually giving a a good opinion that was going
to come out in the end that would eventually be proven correct.
That was his only motivation and the people who were telling
him like that were the ones with the motivated reasoning were
the ones who didn't have their heads on straight and only saw
it through the lens of well I want to protect Ethan Klein because
Hassan Hassan is bad. Han is really bad. So like Pisco being
totally vindicated here is perhaps the best part
by through Pisco's vindication.
>> I and several people like me are also vindicated in
saying that Pisco was obviously just taking the correct side.
Pisco was obviously right. By the way, not a single person ever
challenged Pisco on the logic. Like literally nobody. Nobody
was capable. Nobody could. Nobody even really tried. Hutch tried.
Hutch is a [__] >> right? They they just got
blown out. used. As I previewed weeks ago, if the court relied
on Stebins, Denims would be in a good spot. Completely absent
from the analysis, intentional stated malice.
>> As I've always maintained, I still think Ethan has a
strong claim on the countdown reaction and therefore is likely
to win at least one cause of action. But the nuke reaction by
Denims was always the harder case, especially when compared to
other reactions like
>> This is tentative, yes, but given the language here,
hard for me to see Ethan recovering on the claim, except perhaps
on appeal if he so chooses. >> Dropping the likes in as
you read. Cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. >> Yeah. Meanwhile,
Yeah. Mallerie McMaro was on Hutch's broadcast yesterday apparently.
So, look forward to that massive bump that will take place.
>> Dude, that race is crazy.
That race is insane.
I don't understand how McMora's support evaporated overnight.
She was doing so well the whole race and her support has evaporated.
It was a mirage. It doesn't exist anymore. We are about to see
the McMorro, the hutch bump for McMorrow, so we'll see how that
goes. That might be huge. That some are saying that could turn
the race.
>> The intentionally stated malice was the reason why Ethan
Klein argued that he won't sue Roach or X. He argued because
the three women said, "Watch my stream instead. It is actual
malice." The court didn't even mention that part because it's
irrelevant. >> I'm an IP attorney. This is literally what
I do. Pull me up if you have any
I mean, it was it was obvious that it was Anyway, it was always
it was always going to be. And what was really frustrating for
me,
>> uh, it was obvious it was because he doesn't care about
his copyright. Uh, it's like Broen and and Casey did violate
his copyright. He could say it's because he doesn't care and
he's fully welcoming of people reacting to his stuff. So it's
like in that way it's not as in it's not a valid case. Was watching
so many people not that I had a lot of respect for them. It's
not like I was like, you know, it's not like I respected XQC's
opinion or Asmin Gold's opinion or any of these other like bottom
feeders and their opinions, but it was frustrating to see so
many people get swept away and and uh recognizing that there
was a market for this kind of because at its root, regardless
of my personal feelings about the victims and the circumstance,
what I hate, what I cannot stand is when people
have no investment in the truth. truth. Like when people don't
want to think critically at all and they're excited at the prospect
of just like, you know, uh uh pushing people down while they're
down while a much more powerful, much wealthier content creator
is just like abusing the legal system and the
No, this is actually accurate. You say Scipy says, "Come on,
Hassan. This is a hard cell." No, this is actually accurate.
And this is what turned me off so badly about a bunch of these
people that are totally like totally full of like in my opinion
what happened here was a bunch of people sort of realized that
with Casey Trron it stopped being about copyright and they you
got that apology and those people didn't care. They didn't care
about Ethan Klein not really standing up for copyright. They
didn't care about what what the suit was over. They didn't care
that he got a reward that was not within the bounds of copyright
law, right? That he just came to an agreement. They didn't care
that he compelled speech. They just wanted to see Casey Tron
get her face shoved in the dirt. That's the only thing they were
there for. That's the only thing they live for. And sadly, all
of these people who finally came to that position, they were
all talking about how it was like, "Oh, so good that Ethan Klein
was doing this and he's cleaning up the space." And as soon as
they lost the moral high ground, they totally didn't care. And
they were like, "No, I just want to see Casey get her face shoved
in the dirt."
It's like, "Okay, well, dude, come on, man." And then the apology
obviously went even beyond just getting her face shoved in the
dirt. It was just adding humiliation, heaping humiliation on
top of humiliation. >> Financial power that they have over
someone. Like when I watched the internet celebrate the Caseyron
decision, I couldn't believe how cruel people were.
Like it it just not a single person turned around and went, "Hey,
maybe this is a little up that uh that this bully with a ton
of money is actually going after Casey John." And because a lot
of people
looked at Casey Tron and looked at Denims and looked at Morgan
and saw them as annoying, right, or saw them as not worthy of
of uh uh defense at all, that they just either stood idly by
and let it happen and maybe quietly whispered their discontent
privately
or
they openly celebrated it. And that's again that is like what
it was. I I had this exact conversation with so many people when
I tried to argue this. I'd I'd like walk them down on the points
and then at the end of the conversation they would just go, "Well,
she's an annoying bitch."
Like, you have this whole conversation. You're arguing the points
why it's like not a valid lawsuit. Why Ethan Klein's kind of
a piece of And they go, "Well, yeah, I don't care. She's a It's
like, dude, why why didn't you just say that to begin with? Like,
I literally don't care to argue with you if that's all you're
going to fall back to." It sucks, man. Now, listen. Very important
chat message coming through. Yeah, Ethan literally made Casey
Tron do a ISIS hostage style video. The reason the lawsuit is
so much and then Hassan did this and then Hassan did this was
I think because Ethan Klein was baiting Hansabi to react to his
slob so we could sue him. Yeah. And I never did and I never gave
him that satisfaction. He was driven to the verge of tears begging
on uh camera demanding that I watch his >> This one >> at
which point that probably would have destroyed his chances of
suing me >> Harmony very funny. I think he thought I was
dumb enough to just like lean into this immediately and react
to it. And when I didn't do it, he just lied to his audience
and kept repeatedly saying, "Oh, he's too afraid." And for months
on end, while I'm over here covering Donald Trump, literally
becoming the president and and all of the insanity every single
day, day in day out, regardless of where I am in the on the planet.
I was in Japan, you know, I was traveling. They would just come
in and be like, "Why don't you react? Are you too react?"
Hey, I've seen this tactic before. Why don't you read the transcript?
Why would you READ THE TRANSCRIPT? WHY WOULD you read the transcript?
>> Don't care. Don't care. Don't care.
Very funny. Honestly, if he had sued you, he would have gotten
a he would have gotten a bag off him from counter claims. He
wouldn't have sued. Kuiman, JS, TLK, and a bunch of XX Destiny
fans supporting Casey Tron and the girls. No, I know. That's
what I'm talking about. Like a lot of the uh the orbiters of
like >> Let's go. Let's another shout out on the stream.
He has to he has to try to read a chatter. That chat message
went through like 90 seconds before this, by the way.
>> Huge W. We get the shout out. He knew he had to read
that chat message and give a shout out. Let's go.
Let's go. >> Like pulled away from Destiny's orbit. And
now, >> by the way, I know a lot of people try to frame
it that way as like opposition to Destiny. >> It's not
like that. It's really not.
It's like people sitting in a discord arguing over this precise
for hours on end just makes us have the right positions. Okay,
you get like three four dudes in a room who are ready to argue
on the absolute like minutia of any drama. You just get the right
position.
>> Sorry. That's the way it is, man. You will just arrive
at the correct position. You will be correct. That's that's the
superpower here is we just take a lot of time to watch a lot
of content and actually have a conversation about it.
>> React is not trying to sue popular YouTuber Pegasus.
First of all, popular YouTuber, let's be real. Um, but even went
as far as to look up Singaporean laws he could use against them.
He's trying to sue Pegasus. You're really going to call the government
out on him. He went from I love this dude to he's only mad at
me because I'm hot to I wonder if he's breaking the law to I
wonder if we can eliminate this guy. He's just criticizing you.
This is an evaluation. It's fair. Are you against journalism
now? I thought you like journalists. He's got to be farming.
So, what's really funny about this is Asmin Gold has actively
demanded
that the federal government take care of me sometimes in real
time. Sometimes
[laughter] I do think the government Asigold has asked for Hassan
to be arrested. What is Asigold getting mad about here? Asold
has quite literally quite literally asked for Hassan to be arrested
before. >> Trapped in the confines of a one minute video.
The famous video of him going, "Oh, Hassan would never be brave
enough to be on the streets. Yeah, he's a fake revolutionary.
And then finding out in real time that I was down there and he
and and very quickly turning around be like, "Oh, then he should
be arrested. He should be arrested immediately." And it's really
interesting cuz this guy covers lawsuits all the time unless
it's one of his best friends and it's a suit, right? He loves
lawsuits. He celebrates it. He cherishes it. He farms it, right?
Tone. Okay. >> So, for him to turn around and cry foul
in this moment is very funny. Hey, I mean he's celebrated Ethan's
lawsuits.
He's even actively told his audience that he was it uh that Tech
Dome was and Same with Yes. Yeah. Asmin Gold made his new career
off of the Johnny Depp case. He loves lawsuits. He just hates
it when it's someone who he values as an ideological ally, I
guess. >> I don't know. >> I thought I thought >> I
don't know if Asminold really respects Tecton's political opinion.
Maybe he values him in terms of like gives Aszmigold a little
bit of a shield. Pegasus was his biggest fan, but now he wants
to sue him. What the hell >> It's so funny cuz he has nothing
redeemable about him. >> But the pure animus that drives
a lot of dudes that look like him, I guess, on the internet that
spend every waking moment on the internet. >> The anim
feel towards me is enough. They're like, I don't even want I
will watch the same video over and over again is Chop City. >> It's
It's crazy to me that it's so funny how insecure he is that he
defaults everything down to like his appearance. >> Dog,
I'm sorry. What is the redeemable aspect? I mean, it's one like
there's nothing there. It's not like there's intelligence there.
It's not like there's intellect there. It's not like there's
creativity. There's the same video over and over again. Like,
why does this hit such a sore spot for you,
>> Why is this such a sore spot for you, >> I don't
know why it's a sore spot for Asmin Gold. Obviously, it's weird
for me to watch. Why have you been crying for the past week and
a half since Stavro said you get no
>> so much so that you're now fantasizing about possibly
getting hair transplants, gender affirming surgery.
Okay, that you laser in on this. >> Dude, I keep telling
you guys that Hassan actually missed his calling as a snarker.
Hassan could have been a snarker. Hassan is creepy and weird
and obsessed and online.
He just happened to be born into like a Chad body, but he is
creepy, weird, obsessed, terminally online. He follows this stuff
so so so much, right? He could have been a Starker, but he's
he's doomed to have to be like the leader of a political movement.
What can you do, >> This you laser in on this immediately.
It's just one aspect
of all of the qualities that a person has. We're talking about
a guy who has made the same exact video almost 400 times. The
other thing about how they all say you wouldn't help any of the
lawsuit victims is so annoying. Um I have mentioned um during
the uh Casey Tron saga as well that you will never know and I'm
perfectly happy with that. >> The song creepy. Yeah, creepy.
Not in a to women way cuz that's all about how attractive you
are. [laughter] If you think I would give the satisfaction to
Ethan Klein
on any of these issues uh that that I was uh disturbed or or
in any way, shape, or form involved, you're out of your mind.
Who gives a if his fans also are like such a bad guy? I don't
give a These guys are awful people.
They're awful scumbags. >> So Oh my god. Oh my god. >> They
hate me. Okay, who cares? >> Oh my Oh my god. It's just
so true. So I get it. Yes,
bro. It's like, it's almost like I DM this guy all the time and
we constantly talk about how these people are. It's almost like
we align 100% on everything we think about everybody on the internet.
That's crazy. Chopped gold crying about this. >> It's so
funny how insecure he is that he defaults everything down to
like his >> By the way, I literally did go on to hype up
Pegasus's like self-improvement journey. I think it's awesome.
That is actually one redeemable quality to more Pegasus. I will
always respect that.
It's so funny. Like, no. Obviously, some people just don't like
you because of the things that you're saying. It doesn't have
anything to do with like how you look or anything else. There's
plenty of guys that are, you know, like good-looking guys that
take care of themselves that don't get a million hate videos
made about them. So, it's just like this is the biggest cope
that I've ever imagined. >> I don't I never even remotely
implied that it is my looks that draws so much anger. What the
He's just arguing against the point. >> I feel like other
people have made that point if he hasn't made that point. Oh,
no. Staff was making that point, right? Was it staff? I think
Stavros was making that point for him. Stabros wasn't making
it was like Stabros and Asmin goal both being insecure about
and Han kind of sitting there off to the side, right?
I think Stabros was making that exact point
>> that I didn't make claiming that I'm implying this point.
That's not what I >> It sounds like me just >> Sounds
like me just doesn't want to talk about this, man. It's just
weird to bring up. It's like a personal thing. I don't want to
talk about it, bro. We just could we just not talk about that.
You got to talk about how much you online. This is not required.
This is a weird thing to do.
A impolite to kiss and tell, you know,
>> I guess saying that I'm attractive. It's weird. The
Is this always just like
is this always just like projection central over there? I don't
really watch as many Asmin Gold videos uh especially as of late.
But um kind of feels like he's just kind of feels like he's >> You
really should go after the incel vote. Way more numbers probably.
I just don't identify unfortunately.
>> I It's up, right? >> I do. No, I do think it's
like a way lower
bar to be funny and entertaining and like appeal to the quote
unquote incel quote unquote like incel viewer base. I think it's
like way easier
but I still don't really want to do it, man. I Yeah, he's just
making up arguments and then dunking on those straw man arguments
that he made up.
>> He's just a professional misunderstander at this point.
Why pretend like he has anything worth listening to? Yeah, that's
true. Intentionally causing harassment, alarm, or distress. >> He's
looking up Singapore statutes online. So, he's trying to sue
Pegasus. Oh my god. >> Cause harassment, alarm, or distress
to another person. Called in the section
>> You just don't hate women. Auto rejected. It's better
this way. Well,
>> the thing is is like if you go through life just hating
women and blaming women for all your problems
while wanting to
a that's a terrible state because if you hate women, you're going
to have a hard time women. Okay? Unless you can totally ascend
in a clvicular like fashion, you just are never going to have
sex. So like that's
there is something to just being a like total loser that hates
women and just making it really hard to find a woman.
I'm just telling you
>> that's the way it is. Okay. So if you if you just hate
there's just no reason to >> and all you got to do is look
at your faults and improve yourself. You just be better off.
>> Target person by >> I really don't want to threaten
abusive
you're going to you're going to call you got to someone's got
to make the cliff copy of Asmin Gold demanding that the American
federal government prosecute me celebrating when the American
government intends to prosecute me over and over again. Someone's
got the copy, right? There's got to be cuz there's probably at
least an hour of uninterrupted footage of Asmin Gold first demanding
that I get deplatformed, then demanding that I get sued, then
demanding that the federal government prosecute me, and then
celebrating the federal government implying that they might.
So, [laughter] I just feel like I get this sometimes. I was like,
I'm trying to lay out the storyline for people like I I'm following
and I don't want to direct people exactly, but also how the are
you guys not getting it? Here's what you clip this clip. This
clip, this clip, this clip. You put him in a line, it tells the
story. Holy, I get it. I get how Hassan feels. He's like, he
gets it, he sees it, and he doesn't he's got no shooters. Okay,
need some shooters. Where's his shooters? >> There's probably
at least an hour of uninterrupted footage of Asmin Gold first
demanding that I get deplatformed, then demanding that I get
sued, then demanding that the federal government prosecute me,
and then celebrating the federal government implying that they
might. So again, the most inconsistent
person on the planet. These guys always say like, "Oh, it's the
it's the perception of hypocrisy that is so frustrating, right?"
Like they always say this, they they act as though uh they give
a about hypocrisy at all. It's very cool. For a rabid anti-ocialist,
Ethan Klein Sherlock is being publicly owned. It's true.
>> Oh, dude. Denim's looking smug is just always funny.
It makes like every tweet so funny when you put like any picture
of of Denim, she just looks like the most smug person on planet
Earth.
And
>> it just makes every tweet with her in it like so funny.
>> You're going to call the government out on him? >> Oh
my god, they're going to cane his >> They're going to him.
What are you talking about? >> One of the highest per capita
execution rates globally enforcing capital. >> Wait a minute.
So now he's fantasizing about having Pegasus. >> Who made
this clip compilation? I'm not fantasizing about Pegasus getting
executed. literally as a separate point about the draconian nature
of the Singaporean criminal justice system which I of course
have the utmost respect for. It's the most uh it it maintains
a level of professionalism and integrity that I actually believe
in. Uh just so just so everybody understands I love the nation
of Singapore, my life for Singapore. I will one day visit. Uh
it is the most moral nation on the planet. More moral than >> this
guy this guy doesn't want to get arrested in Singapore. >> Dare
I say Israel. Um >> I get it.
>> this guy doesn't want to get caned, okay? He's not into
that. All right, I think we're good with this. I don't need to
do any of this.
The sand drama aa